five years ago the outgoing Labor
Treasury Minister left a message there's
no money left how can we trust the
Labour Party with the UK economy we just
saw by the way because he kept David
Mary I think hidden camera carried in
his pocket yeah because it's his regular
prop I run a business here in Leeds the
last five years have been really hard
work but we've got a plan now and the
economy is improving what worries me is
your about support Ed Balls back in as a
Chancellor and he called that letter a
joke now let me tell you running a
business the last few years is anything
but a joke and if that's the way your
party wants treat the economy how can we
trust you
well let me tell you very specifically
what I think we need to do for
businesses like yours and this does go
to the big choice at this election
there'll be some people who tell you
that the way we succeed as a country is
as long as a few people at the top do
well and large corporations that's what
powers the economy well I've got a
different view and that's your choice
for the next five years that satisfy you
know hey that wasn't the question asked
you I asked you whiner thigh should
trust a chancellor who thinks a letter
like that was a joke if he worked in the
corporate world he would have been fired
and he would not be allowed back to do
that job
I've just got a really simple question
yeah do you accept that when Labour was
lost in power it overspent no I don't
and I know you may not agree with that
but but let but let me let me just say
very clearly even with all the borrowing
you're on you know I don't let me tell
you because there are schools that have
been rebuilt in our country there are
hospitals that were rebuilt there were
short start centers though there were
short start centers that were built
which would not have happened
Australia didn't suffer this kind of
isn't so for this some of the other
major countries didn't suffer this
country suffered because Gordon Brown
sold gold just as probably social
services how can you stand there and say
you didn't overspend and end up
bankrupting this country that is
absolutely ludicrous you frankly just
lying so I guess I'm not going to
convince you but that the facts speaks
themselves you stood there and said you
didn't overspend if I get to the end of
the week I can't afford to buy a pint
I've overspent it means I am guiding
money later we've got the end of a
government of 13 years and during that
13 year period you spent spent you sold
gold when it was low if we saw the gold
now would be pretty much better off you
can't stand that and so I just come back
importantly a mate but I think I'm not
gonna come if it's a millstone right
let me come back on this because you
said something very important which is
that other some other countries didn't
suffer from that now that's because they
were less exposed to financial services
so I'm sorry financial services
financial services actually put millions
and millions and millions of pounds into
this country millions of pounds which
you'll then spend spend what makes your
view more important than the British
people when it comes to the EU and then
in out referendum where is the life out
there it's actually Alicia so Alicia
Alicia Alicia
um it's about leadership Alicia it's
about leadership on what I want to
achieve as Prime Minister I'm supposing
her voice so you're abused more
important than mine and everybody else
here well it is me I do I do this I do
respect that point of view but I don't
agree with it because I'm putting my
view forward and I think one of the
things you've got Adam let's put our and
what well you do at the general election
thank you very much you sir them